[Music]
we are honoring the legacy of
congressman john lewis this morning
following his death on friday
in our exclusive conversation with bill
and hillary clinton
they told us the best way to remember
john lewis
is by exercising the right to vote that
he fought for and then battled
to protect we should take time off to
honor him
and ask ourselves what was it about john
lewis
that we respected that we love that we
need
and then the rest of us should seek in
our own way
to model that to sort of live for him
and let him live through trying to make
america better
one of the ways to pay tribute to john
lewis
is by finally passing uh the voting
rights act once again with tease and
meaning to it
and naming it after him name it the john
lewis voting rights act and his lifetime
of work and sacrifice and and physical
and emotional stress that came in as he
continued to advocate for every person's
right to have
a vote that would count uh would be the
best tribute we could give him
who picks up the mantle for john lewis
who
is that person i don't think there will
be one person i think there will be
many people there has to be a role that
everyone feels they can and should play
and a song in the heart of everyone like
the song that was in john lewis's heart
people are stepping up and basically
saying send me i'm ready
i want to do my part they know what
we've lost
and of course the very least anybody can
do is to vote
think about what john lewis went through
in order to
get us the right to vote and for
heaven's sakes think about him
in the weeks and months ahead and turn
out
and vote for no other reason than to
honor the legacy of this really great
american
well congressman lewis himself once said
the vote is the most powerful
non-violent tool we have in a democratic
society but i love what the clinton said
there
when they said you know there isn't one
person that can fill his shoes it will
take many how lovely that is to be
remembered that way
that you you that you are considered
irreplaceable and that's what they say
about john lewis today